THIS IS "THE FIVE."
ROUND TWO OF THE ESCALADING FEUD
WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP AND NANCY
PELOSI OVER CLAIMS OF A COVER-UP
AND POSSIBLE IMPEACHMENT.
THE SPEAKER, NOT BACKING AWAY
AFTER SAYING THE PRESIDENT MAY
BE BREAKING THE LAW.
>> WHILE HE TRIES TO SAY IT'S
BECAUSE I SAID COVER-UP, WE'VE
BEEN SAYING COVER-UP FOR A
WHILE.
WHAT REALLY GOT TO HIM IS THESE
COURT CASES AND THE FACT THAT
THE HOUSE DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS IS
NOT ON A PATH TO IMPEACHMENT.
THAT'S WHERE HE WANTS US TO BE.
I PRAY FOR THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
>> I WISH HIS FAMILY OR HIS
ADMINISTRATION OR THE STAFF
WOULD HAVE AN INTERVENTION NOR
THE BENEFIT OF THE COUNTRY.
>> YOU CONCERNED ABOUT HIS
WELL-BE SOMETHING.
>> I AM AND THE WELL-BEING OF
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
>> Dana: PRESIDENT TRUMP FIRING
BACK WITH PERSONAL TAX AGAINST
PELOSI AND CALLING ON AIDES TO
DISPUTE HER CLAIMS THAT HE THREW
A TEMPER TANTRUM.
>> IT'S A DO-NOTHING CONGRESS.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE DONE NOTHING
IN THE HOUSE, DONE ABSOLUTELY
NOTHING.
THEY TONIGHT GET -- OTHER THAN
INVESTIGATE.
THEY WANT TO INVESTIGATE.
SHE SAID I WALKED INTO THE ROOM
NEXT DOOR YESTERDAY AND WALKED
IN AND STARTED SCREAMING AND
YELLING.
JUST THE OPPOSITE.
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT THEY WILL
ALWAYS SAY THAT, EVEN IF IT
DIDN'T HAPPEN BECAUSE THIS
HAPPENED ONCE BEFORE, I WALKED
OUT, I WAS SO CALM.
YOU HAD THE GROUP, CRYING CHUCK,
CRAZY NANCY.
I TELL YOU WHAT, I'VE BEEN
WATCHING HER AND I HAVE BEEN
WATCHING HER FOR A LONG PERIOD
OF TIME.
SHE'S NOT THE SAME PERSON.
SHE'S LOST IT.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, WHY DID YOU
RAISE YOUR VOICE?
>> WE HAD THE MEETING -- HI,
SARAH.
WERE YOU AT THE MEETING?
COME FORWARD.
WHAT WAS MY TONE?
>> VERY CALM.
THIS WAS DEFINITELY NOT ANGRY OR
RANTING.
VERY CALM AND STRAIGHT FORWARD.
>> Dana: GREG, IT'S LIKE THEY'RE
TRYING TO FIND EACH 0
TRYING TO FIND EACHOTHER'S
ACHILLES HEEL.
HE'S TRYING TO SAY OH, SHE'S
LOST IT BECAUSE SHE'S GETTING UP
THERE.
>> I HAVE TO SAY, I WAKE UP
EVERY MORNING AND THANK GOD I'M
ALIVE TO SEE THIS.
IF YOU WERE BORN IN ANOTHER ERA
AND NOT WHILE TRUMP WAS
PRESIDENT, YOU'RE MISSING ONE OF
THE MOST ENTERTAINING IN ERAS.
HE'S LIKE A ONE-MAN CELEBRITY
ROAST.
WHAT SIDE WOULD YOU RATHER BE
ON?
>> YOU DON'T PICK SIDES.
>> NOT AT ALL.
WE HAVE ONE SIDE WHICH IS
CONCRETE ACHIEVEMENT, BUT
IT'S -- BUT IT COMES THE BLUNT,
YOU KNOW, TOTAL CRAZINESS.
OR BEING ON THE SIDE OF NANCY
WHICH IS NO ACHIEVEMENTS AT ALL
AND WAGING A POLITICAL ATTACK
ALL THE TIME.
BEING ON THE ATTACK SIDE IS SO
MUCH EASIER.
BEING A TRUMP SUPPORTER,
WATCHING WHAT HE DOES IS MORE
FUN.
IT'S FUN AND THERE'S
ACHIEVEMENTS.
HOW CAN YOU DO WRONG?
>> Dana: SHE SAYS THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS FRUSTRATED BECAUSE,
JESSE, THE HOUSE IS NOT MOVING
TOWARDS IMPEACHMENT AND THAT'S
WHAT HE WANTS.
MORNING JO TALKED ABOUT THAT.
I HAVE SOUNDS.
>> HE WANTS TO BE IMPEACHED SO
BADLY SO THE SENATE CAN THEN SAY
HE'S NOT GOING TO BE CONVICTED,
CAN ACQUIT HIM.
HE LOVES TO BE VICTIMIZED AS
NANCY PELOSI SAID YESTERDAY.
OH, POOR BABY.
>> Dana: SO THEY THINK THE
PRESIDENT WANTS TO BE IMPEACHED,
BUT HE'S SAYING IF YOU DON'T
IMPEACH OR GET RID OF THIS, WE
CAN DO OTHER THINGS.
>> Trace: HE DOESN'T WANT TO BE
IMPEACHED, THIS IS REVERSE
PSYCHOLOGY FROM NANCY AND CHUCK.
THEY KNOW THAT -- THEY KNOW THE
DEMOCRATS WANT TO IMPEACH.
NANCY DOESN'T WANT IT TO HAPPEN.
SO THEY HAVE TO MAKE IT SEEM
LIKE TRUMP WANTS IT.
OH, WE DON'T WANT TO DO WHAT
TRUMP WANTS.
WHEN BILL CLINTON WAS IMPEACHED,
HIS NUMBERS WENT UP BIG TIME
BECAUSE PEOPLE UNDERSTOOD THE
PAIN HE WENT THROUGH AND SIDED
WITH SOMEONE THAT LIED ABOUT
SEX.
AND THEY OVERREACHED.
TRUMP CAN DO THE SAME MOVES IF
HE DECLASSIFIEDS THE FISA
APPLICATIONS AND ALL THE
INVESTIGATIONS ARE DONE AND
PROVES THAT THE DEMOCRATS
PLANTED EVIDENCE AND SET THIS
ALL UP.
HE WILL LOOK LIKE THE VICTIM AND
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WILL SEE
THAT THIS WAS A SET-UP JOB FROM
THE BEGINNING.
EVERYTHING THAT HAPPENED
YESTERDAY WITH NANCY PELOSI WAS
SPUN INTO A BIG LIE BY THE
MEDIA.
SHE WAS FORCED INTO SAYING THAT
THIS WAS A COVER-UP BECAUSE HER
CAUCUS IS OUT OF CONTROL AND SHE
NEEDED TO SAY SOMETHING.
IT BLEW UP THE MEETING.
NOW SHE'S NOT DELIVERED ON
BORDER SECURITY AND
INFRASTRUCTURE.
IT'S HER CAUCUS OUT OF CONTROL.
IT'S HER THAT HAS NOT DELIVERED
FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND
ACTUALLY HER CAUCUS TRYING TO
OBSTRUCT THE INVESTIGATION INTO
THE WITCH HUNT.
THINK ABOUT IT HONESTLY FOR A
SECOND, JUAN.
WHY WOULD PRESIDENT TRUMP
PARTICIPATE IN ANOTHER ATTEMPT
TO IMPEACH HIM?
IT DIDN'T WORK THE FIRST TIME.
HE WAS FRAMED.
NOT GUILTY.
THEY WANT TO RETRY HIM?
DOUBLE JEOPARDY.
WHY WOULD YOU WALK INTO THAT
TRAP?
AFTER YOU WERE CLEARED, AFTER
YOU WERE FOUND NOT GE
YOU WERE FOUND NOT GUILTY.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE SAYING WE
CAN'T IMPEACH HIM AND HE'S
FIGHTING BACK HARD.
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE.
>> AM I ALLOWED TO RESPOND?
>> YES.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHERE TO START.
FIRST OF ALL, THEY HAVE NOT
TRIED TO IMPEACH HIM YET.
>> THAT'S WHAT IT WAS --
>> YOU SAID THERE WAS A FIRST
TIME.
>> THAT WAS THE ATTEMPT.
>> I SEE.
AND SECONDLY, GUESS WHAT?
IT'S THE COURTS SAYING THAT IN
FACT THE CONGRESS HAS A
LEGITIMATE STANDING AS AN EQUAL
BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT TO HAVE --
>> SO LET THE COURTS DECIDE.
>> THEY'RE SAYING.
GIVE THE DOCUMENTS, THE
FINANCIAL --
>> IT WILL WORK ITS WAY THROUGH
THE COURTS.
>> AND JUST TO DANA'S LARGER
POINT.
NANCY PELOSI IS ONE OF THE FEW
NATIONAL POLITICIANS WHO HAS
TRUMP'S NUMBER.
SHE IS GIVING HIM HIS MEDICINE
IN LARGE DOSES.
IT SEEMS WHEN SHE SAYS THE
FAMILY NEEDS TO INTERVENE AND
I'M PRAYING FOR THE PRESIDENT,
THESE THINGS STING.
IT'S LIKE TRUMP HIGH SCHOOL A
GENIUS OF STINGING NICKNAMES,
NANCY HAS A GENIUS OF SAYING
YOU'RE A LITTLE BIT UNCERTAIN,
YOU'RE WOBBLING AND YOU NEED
HELP O
HELP --
>> SO WE SCRIPTED IT AS PERSONAL
ATTACKS BUT WHEN SHE DOES IT
IT'S NOT?
>> DOES ANYBODY BELIEVE THAT
NANCY PELOSI IS PRAYING FOR THE
WELL-BEING OF PRESIDENT TRUMP?
I THINK THAT HER PRAYERS DIDN'T
WORK.
>> SHE'S PRAYING FOR US, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE UNDER THAT
PRESIDENT.
>> NO, SHE SAID SHE WAS PRAYING
FOR THE PRESIDENT.
>> I CAN'T BELIEVE WHAT YOU SAID
ABOUT THE MEDIA.
I WAS READING THE PAPERS THIS
MORNING.
I THOUGHT WOW.
I KNOW CONSERVATIVES SAY THIS
LIBERAL MEDIA IS SO ANTI-TRUMP.
THEY BOUGHT TRUMP'S STORY THAT
IN FACT PELOSI HAD STARTED
THIS --
>> SHE DID.
>> NANCY PELOSI AND CHUCK
SCHUMER, EVERYBODY SAID, THERE'S
BEEN AN INVESTIGATION GOING ON
ALL ALONG.
AND THEY MET WITH EACH OTHER.
BUT NOW OH, HE WAS SO UPSET BY
WHAT THE NANCY SAID.
>> COVER UP?
>> FIRST OF ALL, I'M NOT CLEAR
ON WHY WE HAD A SPECIAL COUNSEL
INVESTIGATION IF CONGRESS IS
JUST GOING TO REDO THE
INVESTIGATION AND WASTE A BUNCH
OF MORE MONEY TO COME TO A
DIFFERENT OR SAME CONCLUSION.
PROBABLY THE SAME CONCLUSION
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE THE SAME
NUMBER OF RESOURCES THAT A
SPECIAL COUNSEL DOES.
GETTING BACK TO THE ISSUES THAT
THE PRESIDENT WAS TALKING ABOUT
TODAY IN TERMS OF TRADE AND
CHINA.
CHUCK SCHUMER AGREES WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP ON CHINA.
HE'S ONE OF THE PEOPLE BACKING
HIM UP AND SAYING WE KNOW
THERE'S PAIN, THIS IS VERY
DIFFICULT FOR THE MIDDLE OF THE
COUNTRY.
BUT CHINA IS CHEATING AND WE
AGREE WITH THE PRESIDENT.
THERE'S SOMETHING LONG-TERM
THERE.
THE REPLACEMENT TO NAFTA IS
ANOTHER ONE.
THE DEMOCRATIC BASE LIKES THE
UNION WORK.
THEY LIKE THE INFRASTRUCTURE
SPENDING.
TRUMP KEEPS COMING TO THEM WITH
PLANS, PUBLICLY IN THESE PRESS
CONFERENCES AND YOU CAN DRAG
THEM OUT BECAUSE IT'S AN EVENT
OF SOMETHING ELSE AND HE'S
OFFERING IT TO EVERYONE TO SEE
AND DEMOCRATS ARE NOT WILLING TO
DO THAT.
>> Dana: ANDPELOSI HAS AN EXCUSE
SAYING WE CAN'T GET ANYTHING
DONE BECAUSE PRESIDENT TRUMP
WOULDN'T WORK IT WITH US.
THEY FIGURE OUT A WAY TO BLAME
HIM.
>> REMEMBER, THE REPUBLICANS HAD
CONGRESS FOR TWO YEARS.
BOTH HOUSES.
>> AND EVERYBODY BLAMES THEM.
>> IT'S THE DEMOCRATS.
>> WHAT IS INTERESTING ABOUT THE
IMPEACHMENT ARGUMENT, THE
IMPEACHMENT ARGUMENT THAT
MORNING BLOW SAID, HE WANT
IMPEACHMENT BUT SO DOES HE SO
LET'S NOT GIVE IT TO HIM.
SAME AS THE BOARD.
BUT BECAUSE HE WANTS A STRONG
BORDER, WE'RE NOT GOING TO DO
IT.
THEY'RE INFANTS.
THEY'RE NOT ADULTS.
>> IT'S LIKE HOW YOU TREAT
CHILDREN.
FIGURE OUT A WAY OH, THEY TRIED
TO REVERSE PSYCHOLOGY BUT
EVERYONE -- WE'RE ALL ADULTS.
WE'RE FOLLOWING ALONG.